so just want to pull out a few things
from the examples or the questions I
just assigned and then we'll move on for
the next little mini concert I promise
it won't be like a big one hopefully you
found that was not long you just have to
apply it and get used to that okay and
I'll be the same with this so I ask you
do 1 2 & 9 and there were some good
questions that came out of each I hope
you realize um this really and we said
this right in the first lesson it brings
together a lot of the mathematics we've
learned over the last like term and a
half and so for example this particular
one here the concept we wanted you to
get in this question was where are the
boundaries of this integral right I'm
from memory this particular probability
density function it's defined from x
equals 50 and then onwards
can you just double-check that question
to see the domain right so it's like Oh
on my um what if my graph looks like
right it starts at 50 so whatever
happens before 50 I don't really care
about that and then they asked for the
probability in less than 60 right so
this is the section or this is the
domain that I'm interested in so that's
where my lower and upper boundaries come
from 50 to 60 but in a sense even though
that's kind of a main theme of the
questions about once you do that that's
just where your problems begin because
this is not like an easy integral by any
stretch you have to think back a lot to
how do you like form this into something
that's easy to work with there's a
fraction here which might make you think
ah is this one of those log integral
like it's gonna end up with log it's not
because if you've made this denominator
f of X the numerator it doesn't look
anything like f dash X right and what
would it be on the top if you wanted
this to be f of X this would have to be
something like a like an X cubed of some
kind right because it should only be one
step down from the index right so you're
like it's not that's no good okay so
what we have to do instead is take that
one big fraction and break it into two
pieces which you can then you have to
use your index laws again lots of prior
knowledge that you need to call on and
then from there you actually can safely
integrate it you still end up with some
gross stuff here but once you put this
into a form like I would probably on the
X line I would write that as minus one
over two x squared can you see what I
did there
negative on the bottom from this
negative to comes up the top that's
where we usually write them and that X
to the power of negative two really
means you're dividing by X we're not
multiplying this here it's like it's
still gross right you've got fifty over
three and you can see I've cancelled
that double negative right
this thing is what we're going to put
our 50 and our 60 into and your
calculator is going to do that work okay
but you can see the integration right
it's it's still part of the challenge
obvious and this is question I in the
last one I'll asked you to do in that
little set here and you're like oh trig
functions it's been a while since we
dealt with these right so you want to
think about the fact that if you were to
differentiate from something and land
here because that's the opposite of what
we're doing here what function do we
start with that differentiate into Sonne
think carefully hmm what do I
differentiate to land on here it's going
to be sine X right that differentiates
into then it's so tricky right because
you have minus signs flying around sign
just goes into cause when you're
differentiating right when you
differentiate again that goes into minus
sign right so you're like oh I don't
have a minus sign here right so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna start to reshape
this so that it will integrate into
something that I know how to deal with
so for example I'm gonna pop up my
design right at the front my boundaries
are still the same that minus sign out
the front
I sort of compensate for it with another
minus sign on the inside so this is
looking a little better for me I know
that I can differentiate back up into
cos x but I'm still out of the woods yet
right this comes from sorry there's a DX
hanging out on the in there this comes
from a use of chain rule right see that
PI X on six inside the brackets right so
it's really PI on six times X PI and six
is just a constant yeah it could have
been a two or three or minus one okay
so therefore this guy here would have
come out the front when I did chain rule
so I want a pylon 6 to be there it's not
a pound 6 so how do I turn this into a
pound six what can i factor eyes out to
make that upon 6a - right but just be
careful with your - because it's a -
that's on the denominator do you see
that the denominator is bigger than I
want it to be so I want to put a minus
1/2 out the front that leaves me with a
minus PI on 6 on the inside and you're
like aha
this thing I can deal with if you go to
your reference sheet this is one of the
results actually there's not word for
word but that's what it looks like right
you've got your FX here and there's your
f - ok so now I'm good to go I can now
just say that's going to be cos of Pi on
6x and you'll take your numbers and
evaluate ok so I'll leave those there
for a minute because I know this is the
stumbling block this is the knowledge
that it's like I'm trying to grab for
this and it's just been weeks and months
since I've rehearsed it so I'll leave
that there for you guys to have a look
at